Due to the pandemic, many of us will most likely be doing our holiday shopping online,...
...but before you start loading your cart and inputting that card number,...
...you may want to take a step back to make sure your transaction is safe...
...and you're applying deals when they're available.
Check comparison sites and reviews to ensure you're getting a good deal.
Look for reviews about the seller's reputation and customer service.
You'll also want to look for coupon codes.
You can search the retailer's name with the terms "discount," "coupon" or "free shipping."
Check if the website's address starts with "https."
If you don't see the "s," which stands for "secure," don't enter your information.